let's tell you about what's happening in
Spain we had the latest figures from
there in the last hour at 12,000 418
people have died in total from the virus
that's an increase of 674 on the
yesterday's total we can speak to our
correspondent Alex Cross he was in
Madrid for us Alex you know still high
numbers numbers that we're seeing across
several countries in Europe but Spain
like Italy and France are starting to
see a decrease yeah there is muted
optimism here really about what is
happening I suppose it's quite telling
about what this disease is doing to
countries when you're looking at very
very grim figures indeed still hundreds
of people losing their lives to kovat 19
but you are seeing some hope even in
those horrendous figures so the figures
today six hundred and seventy four
deaths as you were saying that's down
from 809 yesterday that's the lowest
level that this country is seen in nine
days remember they had that record high
on Thursday passing that grim milestone
of 10,000 deaths at 950 recorded on
Thursday but they are seeing hope in
these numbers as I was saying the in
number of infections is also going down
as well that is also cause for hope you
look at the infections now standing in
the country 130,000 759 up 6023 so that
is quite a dramatic fall health
officials are talking about the lockdown
here working it's now been extended to
April the 25th and what's happening is
that they're seeing that the curve is
being suppressed it's been flattened and
that means of course that they're being
able to get their health system in
better shape to deal with these cases
that are coming in if the systems are in
place in the health service they also
have a chance for the more serious cases
of saving lives
so the lockdown is continuing but they
are having some hope here that what they
have put in place is beginning to work
tough as it has been